This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there.
This is The Chris Abraham Show
season five Episode 55.
I'm Chris Abraham, and it's a
glorious day here in Northern
Virginia S Arlington, and I am a
man called Chris Abraham.
I'm highly amused with
whatever's going on with Trump
at all because every action has
an equal and opposite reaction.
And.
Under the guise of by any means
necessary, there are going to be
secondary effects that are going
to happen for the next 50 years.
So used to be that the left and
right both knew that attacking a
current or former president in
ways above words and press was
mutually assured destruction.
There was a kind of a date hunt.
Based on the fact that people
knew that coming after a former
president was a terrible
precedent and to do such a thing
would quickly result in terrible
side effects, which is to say,
the first person who attacks not
only defines not only defines
the the fight, but actually
creates the floor of the fight.
So.
By relying things like Rico or
going after someone legally for
things that are clearly
protected under free speech in
the First Amendment.
To go after a former president
over horse trading and
aggressive negotiations and
going after president for things
that are totally on not only
tape but video.
Recorded in a time before deep
fakes where people like Hillary
Clinton and everybody else is
calling for the same kind of
thing, the exact same kind of
thing.
And it's very easy to show
hypocrisy and to and people
think that.
Like, for example, in college I
stole Karen Chulupsky from my
fraternity brother.
Because I was better looking and
the girl was into me and but it
didn't matter.
The rules of the game were that
even though my brother hadn't
slept with Karen, it doesn't
matter.
Even though he was in the
friends zone, he's still at dibs
on Karen Chilupski.
So ergo, like I, as a brother in
the fraternity based on bro
rules, was like.
Prevented through good form and
norms and values from pursuing
her.
But she was so ripe on the vine
and I'd never seen a girl like
that.
And I wanted her so badly.
And she looked at me with those
eyes, and those weren't just
pretty eyes.
Those were eyes that wanted me.
And that wasn't normal either.
So I I went for it like and we
had a a crazy, passionate,
heartbreaking.
Romance over the end of term and
the beginning of the summer.
We even lived together at a
really Roach infested DuPont,
like 14th and R 13th and R
maybe?
Was it DuPont or was it wasn't
DuPont, It was like 13th, 13th
and R maybe.
Anyway, the story was is it was
too good to not do in the short
game, but the rules of
engagement.
Are very clear with regards to
what is and isn't civil because
those are well hewn, well
discerned, well tested laws over
thousands of years that say if
you are opportunistic then even
though you know it's even though
the situation is dire in your
mind and you're literally
preventing Hitler.
A vindictive and openly
vindictive and revenge seeking
next president who is obviously
going to become president if all
things are created equal and if
democracy works according to the
way it should.
Representative democracy, I'm
saying, with regards to just the
timber timber of the of the
nation.
I mean black folks and Latin
folks and immigrants and
Mexicans and Salvador, like a
lot of people are going to vote
for Trump.
So you need to get Trump off the
table and by any means
necessary, which is to say,
breaking all constitutional
interpretations, breaking all
previous interpretations of
Rico, breaking all
understandings of the 1st
Amendment and.
And the right to use words and
forceful ways.
And the and the precedent for
horse trading and go get me
this.
And.
And threats and Saber rattling
and all this other stuff.
All these precedents that people
completely understand and both
sides use rigorously and
vigorously to the point of pain,
to the point of Gitmo
interrogator just short of
waterboarding.
Now that.
The By any means necessary
stricture is being implemented.
All bets are off, all gloves are
off, and everybody's got a
knife.
And it's not.
It's not 20 paces.
It's not gentlemanly.
It is jungle rules.
So it's not even Octagon.
It's freaking jungle rules.
It's it's it's the equivalent of
cutting off the ears of your
enemies.
And stringing them up onto a
necklace to show your kills.
And everybody who is a,
everybody who is a Neolib
Liberal Democrat is going to get
rewarded for every year that
they have on their necklace,
whatever the outcome in the
future.
If you martyred yourself, no
matter what the outcome, if you
hobbled or took out or threw
your bolo at the feet.
Of the former president.
If you took your shot.
If you showed your loyalty, if
you sacrificed your bar
membership, your legal Como D
your legal license.
If you sacrificed your I don't
know your understanding of the
law of the Constitution.
If you played rough and tumble
with the truth.
If you lied under oath.
Anything to prevent this
vindictive monster, this former
future current Nazi Hitler.
You know, freaking Stalin,
Lenin, Putin.
Voldemort.
Literally.
You know, monster, Satan.
Devil, coward.
Stud monster.
Fat shit, piece of shit, orange
man.
Bad.
Like if you were going to What
do they say in the dating world?
Take a shot.
You will be rewarded whether or
not that shot hits.
Because even if you were willing
to put on the bomb vest and you
were willing to go into the Into
the Fresh Market in the middle
of town on a Sunday, when
everybody's there, whether or
not, when you push the button,
whether or not the vest
detonates.
It proves to everybody you
didn't know that.
It proves to everybody that you
were willing to blow up your
entire career.
You were willing to blow up an
entire market full of civilians.
You were willing to take and do
whatever it takes to prevent by
any means necessary.
And I'm surprised they haven't
tried to assassinate Trump.
Yikes.
That's the next step, right?
That's the.
That's the if, if by any means
necessary, means that you're
going to probably try to take a
literal poke at the big guy,
right?
So all that being said, this is
going to ruin a lot of careers
on both sides.
This is going to make becoming
president in even more toxic
than it was before.
But not only that, it's going to
make it toxic to be a judge,
it's going to make it toxic to
be a public defender.
It's going to be toxic to be a
public prosecutor.
It's going to be toxic to be of
counsel.
It's going to be toxic to be a
lawyer.
politician.
It's going to be toxic to be a
mayor, a governor, ADA in a USA,
anything, anything.
It's going to be going from
being deep state to being
surface state.
There's going to be so much
attention and energy spent.
At popularizing and turning, the
people used to be dark in the
background, just doing their job
into not only public officials,
but people are going to be
actively doxxed, actively
intimidated.
Nobody's going to want to
volunteer as a as a juror.
Nobody's going to want to be a
juror.
Why would you want to be a
juror?
If someone outs you, or if
someone intimidates you?
Or if you're convinced that if.
You get doxxed and revealed for
judging for or against the wrong
right person.
Then your life is you've.
Your life has gone public,
You've been revealed.
People are going to try even
harder to avoid como the jury
duty, because what price, right?
What price?
Before, people didn't want jury
duty because it would
inconvenience them.
They didn't want to do it.
They thought it was beneath
them.
They had money to make that
mouse to fill.
Jury duty is something that's
nice if you have nothing else to
do.
If you're homeless or unemployed
or bored or, you know, housewife
or husband, wife or whatever,
house husband, you know, if you
ain't got nothing going on, if
you don't, if you ain't got no
hustle, then you can do jury
duty.
But now jury jurors are putting
their life.
On the line.
This is more of a sacrificial
lamb moment and I don't know
like the only people who would
willing to martyr themselves for
the act of like it's like a self
selecting thing, right?
You never want the president to
be anybody who wants to be
president.
You never want an NGO to be
headed by someone who is a true
believer.
You want someone with a with a
savvy mind, you know you want
someone who has.
Insouciants who has a certain
level of professional distance
so as to keep a little bit of
separation between, you know, to
make sure that you don't Icarus
yourself and ever go so close to
the sun, right?
And we're learning more and
more.
The downsides of fame, the
downsides of celebrity, the
downsides of of virality.
You have the woman.
And I think she's hot too.
Like, I totally think that the
crazy woman on the plane is
stone cold Fox, the one who's
like, you don't know that MF ER
is not real, that MF ER is not
real.
Like, that's my kind of girl
anyway.
So I don't know, like, back to
this, like, it's not about
Trump, It's about the precedent.
And it's about the gauntlet
thrown down.
And the gauntlet thrown down
doesn't include.
Head guards, doesn't include
face guards, doesn't include
mouth guards, doesn't include
padded kidney pads.
It doesn't include only above,
only above the the belt.
It doesn't include big puffy
boxing gloves.
This is now to Fight Club,
right?
And I'm entertained by Fight
Club.
I like seeing someone.
Be brought to the brink of death
by getting accidentally hit in
such a way that something
terrible happens and there's
extreme brain trauma, but I'm
fucked up?
So what means now?
What?
What by anything's necessary
means that?
I mean, listen, the right
understands all this, the right
understands this and is really
leery about going full Neolib,
right?
But it's going to happen
eventually.
And like the biggest fear in the
last 50 years that I've known as
a consistency is nobody wants to
wake the giant.
Nobody wants to wake the giant.
There's incredible, like
consistency by the left and the
right with regards to taxes and
unemployment and opportunism and
capitalism.
And religion and guns.
Like, everybody's afraid of
waking up this extremely.
Like they're still living in the
1970s.
They're still living in the
1950s.
1980s.
They're still living in the
1990s.
These people who are just like
Metro, bordo, dodo, they're just
working for a living, Working
for a living.
Huey Lewis on the news.
I forget all the rest of the
lyrics.
There's a great next line that I
can't remember.
Please remind me.
Como dia?
Yeah.
So now that the gloves are off,
what's going to happen?
Is there always going to be this
level of danger?
Is it going to result in even
worse prospects for judges, for
defendants, for prosecutors, For
defenders?
Is are people going to be leery
of criminal law?
Are people going to be leery?
Public service.
Are people going to be leery
even of joining things like
school boards or joining things
like local elections or city
town village elections?
Are people not going to want to
volunteer in the Police
Department?
That's already happening?
Are people not going to be want
wanting to be FBI agents?
Are people not going to want to
be?
Homeland Security agents are
people not going to want to be
US Marshals.
Are people not going to want to
be shit working for sheriff's
departments?
Whether it's state or local,
there's going to be opportunity
cost because if there's no rules
and there's no protection, and
the thin blue line doesn't have
any guards up to protect itself
from the slings and arrows of
public prosecution.
And hearts and minds.
Warfare.
And if you know that even if you
do a good kill on the wrong
person, that record will be
memory hold and they'll still.
Your life will still be ruined.
And the person that you
righteously killed in defense of
yourself for another, or your
brothers.
And in blue, no you don't
remember, It won't matter.
The dirtbag will still become a
martyr.
And be celebrated every year for
his brutal, unjust police
killing.
So, so you know, and I mean the
first warning shots have
everything to do with with
Hunter Biden.
So depending on how well Hunter
Biden survives this attack, and
depending on how below the belt
or how.
You know knuckle sandwich or how
like Shiv, there's going to be,
there's going to be prison
fighting, right?
There's going to be shivs,
there's going to be box cutters,
there's going to be brass
knuckles, there's going to be
push daggers, there's going to
be saps.
It's going to be freaking
awesome.
And and the left is going after
Jared Kushner, and that's
proactive against the Hunter
Biden.
But nobody will ever stop.
Pursuing Hunter Biden and Biden
really should just lose and die
or do his next term and die
because he will always be
hunted.
And the crazy thing is that the
whole idea of Biden crime family
has now become kind of etched in
stone and everybody who's to the
right of center, right?
Is only saying Biden Crime
family.
They're not saying the Biden's.
They're not saying, you know
what is it Linda or Lydia or
Larry?
What?
What's Biden's wife's name?
Mrs. Doctor Biden.
And it's going to be really fun
to see what revenge looks like.
It'll be even crazier to see
what Trump's revenge is if he
happens to avoid.
Capture, become the next
president and then self, you
know, self liberate himself.
Pardon.
Self pardon, Which they say is
unprecedented, but add that
unprecedented self pardoning to
the giant pile.
I mean, back in the day with
JFK, everybody knew that John F
Kennedy and Bobby Kennedy were
boning Marilyn Monroe, but it
was just.
It was just not done.
People didn't, people didn't
consider and this is the way the
French, the French President was
always treated.
There is you are the office of
the president and anything
outside the office of the
president is, is off, is off the
reservation.
Now it'll be really interesting
to see what happens with regards
to Barack Obama.
Right now they're spending a lot
of time on podcasts and Fox
News, and it's mostly on
podcast, like Alex Jones and
Glenn Beck and No Agenda Show
and even Megyn Kelly, where
they're going on and on and on
that it's still there, that that
Obama's our first Kenyan
president and Obama's our first
gay president and Michelle
Obama, who they call Big Mike,
is our first trans first lady.
So like, that's happening and
that's becoming way more popular
and it's just really
entertaining and I'm not allowed
to eat popcorn, but I just don't
know where it's going to go.
And everybody always creates a
giant distraction in order to
distract away from these sort of
diabolical and quite quite
possibly mutually destructive in
fights.
But I mean, we're completely not
caring at all about Maui,
really.
We're completely not caring at
all about Ukraine.
We don't care about Russia at
all anymore.
We don't care about like Assad,
Syria we don't care about and we
don't care about about knees
there.
We don't care about the Coos
We don't care about anything
that's happening in the world of
of Central and South America.
We really don't care what's
going on actually in Mexico.
So with all that being said, I
mean I don't even think we'll
care if there is like a low
yield nuclear, like local area,
local like nuclear catastrophe
because this, this country is
extremely NIMBY and everybody
doesn't want to wake up.
Like I said, the Moral majority,
those naturally conservative
people who just want to be left
alone.
And if you wake them up, they
could organize in a very
hysterical manner, in a way that
would make the 20% that are
currently pawning or owning us
as a country, dominating us,
leading us, transitioning us,
training us, culturally,
revolutionizing us.
All.
Those people are going to really
realize that they're only 20% of
the population.
And when the 80% gets annoyed
enough, the backhand of the 80%
against the little guy is
generally not only terrifying,
but completely destructive and
way more painful than the types
of trauma that most people are
celebrating in their relatively
gentle, sweet first ish world
lives.
Anyway, I'll talk to you soon, I
hope you're well.
This was season five, episode 55
of The Chris Abraham Show
Mahalo.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.